We are dealing with just the little bit of
crazy to close out the year. The last Patriot
mail of the year is a doozy. Quick reminder
about what Patriot mail is.
I N Rand and Ronald Reagan had a baby and
suckled that child off the teat of Liberty.
It's cries would sound a little [inaudible]
like, Hey [inaudible] written by Patriots.
Who hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom.
All right, so let's get right into this week's
hatred. Mail a day early because we are off
on January 1st for the new year's day holiday
hatred mail. This guy giving us really a lot
of material to work with here.
What a joke. His is obvious 750,000 subscribers.
We know all about that. David beta, Pacman,
you don't know. Boy, why don't you leave this
to the professionals. If we ever need a report
on how to be a cook, we'll let you know. Peple
you want to see a weak, desperate man look
no further than this guy King cook, David
pack man.
750,000. No, no, my friend, we're at close
to 790,000 YouTube subscribers and I will
say onward and upward into 2020 with 1 million
subscribers being the target. It's been truly
an incredible year in hatred, autism. And
sadly, and you know, we, we, we joke around
about the hate mail that we get and we, we
sometimes, uh, wonder aloud how it is that
people end up being in a position in their
lives where they choose to write into a show
like this one with this type of hatred and
vitriol. But this stuff translates to the
real world. And not to turn this into a very
special episode of hatred, mail, but I unfortunately
expect that this is going to get worse in
2020 with it being an election year. Um, but,
uh, we will be here and we will continue doing
everything we can to, uh, put out what we
believe is a perspective that will improve
the country.
We're, we're looking to build things and to
do things rather than to uh, tear down, which
is much of what we see as a theme in hatred
mail. We laugh about it but that is a theme
tearing down things, uh, that people are trying
to do.